how's the gum resin today we're gonna
play with some of the oculus it's been a
while let's do it
ah hmm first game should hopefully be
amazing oh my [ __ ] god
Pokemon VR either oh my god oh this is
cool
this is [ __ ] cool Oh ah [ __ ] oh my
god my pants I have [ __ ] hands this
is the weirdest thing ever
ah oh I can molest pokemons this is
great
do I do I just like throw oh my god no
no it works so well with it the thing on
my face look at this it's so weird to
have my [ __ ] hand in the game I were
over there for that [ __ ] matter but
oh my god is so [ __ ] cool I want to
cry I want to cry manly tears of
coolness yeah yes yes right [ __ ] car
- Pokemon their sister granite dama
laughs I never tried this on with the
octal it's it's [ __ ] cool it's really
[ __ ] cool I want to do more like that
okay here we go this one is called
Kinesis level one oh my god what the
[ __ ] is happening hi guys oh my god I
have my hand oh my god this is so
[ __ ] cool oh my [ __ ] god oh my god
oh my god oh my I can't I can't I can't
this is this oh my god what are you
doing oh my god it's like science I
can't I can't
I'm [ __ ] Bay during this [ __ ] I'm
fading paper oh my god I can check my
[ __ ] time
oh my god I'm here I'm in the game I can
and this is this is soap the [ __ ]
mined area with this guy ha ha ha
it's so [ __ ] cool to see your [ __ ]
hand in VR in real time like it's it's
so it's so [ __ ] cool
I can I can just [ __ ] stare on my
hand I'm like a hit be like oh my hand
oh my god I have yellow hands yeah I've
been dipped in butter
oggi [ __ ] you almost peace hey PC me
Betty how do I kill people
Oh God hey hugs ah [ __ ] I spicy yeah
what is it is it a 10 out of 10 best
game ever oh my god ah my face is
melting ah well oh my god I can see my
screen oh my god
what the [ __ ] this is like you bros can
see me ah my dicket's ha ha where's that
gay there you are oh my god you creepy
little [ __ ] and God how you doing in
the game each fire and I now I get out
what do you think yeah he likes it a bit
too much I don't like it it's so weird
hi this is weird [ __ ] is going on oh
[ __ ] no my thumb hey I got blood
everywhere I'm driving a car uh I get
what talk about what yeah where is this
girl she's kind of scaring me to be
honest
I got ya stop doing that what kind of
road is this anyway what what just
happened I don't know
Oh what the [ __ ] is that uh what is that
oh that's so creepy oh no no I don't
what are you doing stop walking
oh god oh god don't eat me alive I
probably don't taste very good cuz
because I I am very malnutritioned I am
you might want to go with my wife she's
a lot fatter someone's eating my ass oh
my ass someone's nearly eating my
[ __ ] ah what the [ __ ] are you
what the [ __ ] ah hey honey ah stop stop
stop stop stop
no no oh
oh oh oh I get it I was a werewolf that
took me way too long project jump-scare
warning high-intensity gameplay wait I
get a gun what the what I don't want a
gun
Oh No Oh guys shut up say Jen aah
I'm alive huh no oh stop hitting me you
piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] sweet rational man man oh my god
no more please
discrete that of it not today not today
not today three to six girls they wanna
have fun
no it's Puetz pills just wanted to have
fun
Oh pills just wanted to have fun but
that's not what he gave
it you're not gonna [ __ ] talk to me
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] suck my ass
you [ __ ] nephew take a sniff a fake
daniella feet are held back that no no
no no no now get this [ __ ] you got this
bros [ __ ] here you [ __ ] sneaky
mother [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh hey y'all get the man fun how much
help do you have
I'm just running now I'm just ready
[ __ ] oh my god I did it I [ __ ] did
it
I did it
ah I [ __ ] dare to press oh my god -
my face